uh i have a question about uh my
favorite
not even tertiary character
i wonder i wonder uh dick and man woody
was that on purpose uh you know it's
been so long ago
[Laughter]
i came across that name somewhere i
don't remember where now man
man woody and dicken of course was a was
a common middle ages
uh nickname or variant for richard
uh dick and ricken uh they were there
were things like that
um
but i don't know where i encountered the
name man woody but just seemed
cool so i i threw it in there yeah
there's it's
uh there's a very they have a very
impressive house that i like like
they're
heraldry their castle is called king's
rave and
dick and man you can't
hear that name and not laugh there are
some of the names of the minor
characters who are
my uh homages to other other fantasy
writers or other people that i admire
they're not going to be major characters
they're sort of background characters
but there's a whole
there's actually two branches of house
vance you know which is my uh
tip of the hat to jack vance um one of
the great fantasists of our time and
science fiction writers of our time
whose work has
been tremendously influential on i think
not just me but a whole generation of uh
science fiction and fantasy writers and
similarly there's uh
there's a house rogers which is uh from
my friend rodgers the lake rushes lazney
and uh
there's a house jourdain of the tour
which is for my friend uh robert jordan
and they're
you know they're just background things
but it's just my way of
of uh nodding to some fellow fantasists
the uh the dothraki
what exactly did you have in mind for
them i i kind of get uh
kind of flashes of uh mongolians maybe
even
uh american indians yes that they they
are that
you know i don't want to do with any of
my i don't know historical references i
don't like to do one
one to one things i don't like to just
take a figure from history
and erase his name and give him a new
fantasy name
and but he's exactly the same as the
figure from history and he goes through
the same things
i like to mix and match and sort of take
you know you want the historical thing
because it grounds you
it gives you it gives you something
that'll help make it a little more
gritty and realistic but then you want
to
maybe take something from this character
and something from that character and
add a twist or an element of imagination
and you get a
hopefully a new character who can be
seen to be influenced by these
historical figures
but is different and that's certainly
true with the dothraki i mean
many people have equated them with the
mongols of genghis khan and
the golden horde and all that and
certainly there's a lot of that there
but but they're not just the mongols
they're significantly different from the
mongols in a number of ways in their
religion
and in their level of technological
sophistication
in their history i've also borrowed from
them
from certain of the other step peoples
uh of the great eurasian step the allens
who preceded the mongols the uh the huns
who were of course uh a thousand years
earlier
and then as you say the uh the
amerindian tribes of
of the american plains uh the cheyenne
and the sioux
uh and to that i've added a fantasy
element i've added uh
some twists that that was not true of
any of those peoples but is true of my
my dothraki so hopefully make them a
people who are
inspired by all of these things but have
their own uh fictional
fantastic identity